hi i'm doug Koshland I'm a professor at
the University of California Berkeley in
the department of molecular cell biology
the specialty in genetics so my
laboratory tries to study two
fundamental problems of cell biology
which is how two cells ensure that
during each cell division their
chromosomes get inherited to each the
new daughter cells and we also try and
understand how cells deal with stress
and in this case particularly how they
deal with the absence of of water well I
had an interest in problem solving had
interest in science but what happened
probably for me was I was many like many
young people I was thinking about
possibly being a doctor as well as a
scientist and I had had a series of jobs
being a factory warehouseman doing
bookkeeping and then I had an
opportunity to spend a little time in a
science laboratory and realized I wasn't
looking at the clock so that was the
sort of realization that there was
something magical that fascinated me
that where time was no longer something
I was concerned about that sort of was
the first thing and you realized I
wanted to be a scientist